you think more women would be part of  the one percent not necessarily because  we live in a patriarchal society you  think it's because of the patriarchy oh  of course 100 okay why there's nothing  stopping me if I want to be a CEO  um no there is because you're gonna be  talking yeah historically it's  patriarchal society of course men are  men and they're saying like what does  that have to do with me today I was born  like I was born in 1996. okay okay yeah  I'm saying like oh yeah if anything I  think it's easier to be a woman and at  most jobs like I would say I've been  given better treatment because in Europe  or in the us both that's incorrect